Why do airplanes have flaps? You
probably been wondering this even before
you decided to become a pilot. I believe
that flaps are one of the most important
[music] tools that a pilot has at his
disposal, and today I'm going to explain
why an airplane has flaps and how you
can use them to make flying way safer
and way easier.
Welcome to Free Pilot Training. I'm
Josh, and today we're talking about one
of my favorite flight controls, the
flaps. Now, flaps are a secondary flight
control. They're not a primary flight
control like the rudder or the aileron,
but they're still super important. Flaps
make flying so much safer, and I'll
explain why that is in just a minute.
But first, let's foot stomp a couple
things that you need to know for the FAA
written exam. For the written exam, I
want you to remember two things about
the flaps. First, they increase the lift
that a wing produces, and second, they
increase the drag that your wings
produce as well.
This in turn allows the airplane to
descend at a steeper angle during
approach. And that's super handy because
anytime you pitch the nose of your
airplane down, the airplane likes to
speed up. And this actually creates more
lift, which makes it harder to descend.
As you can see, this can make things
more difficult. One second, you're
descending towards the runway, and then
the next, the airplane is leveling off
because you sped up and the wings
decided to create more lift. All the
while, you, as a new pilot, don't even
realize it, and then you end up going
around instead of landing because you're
too high. And your instructor's letting
you learn all this the hard way. Yeah,
what a turd.
Or you could have lowered the flaps to
help yourself descend because the flaps
increase the drag on your wings. And
this allows you to increase your decent
angle without increasing your airspeed.
Remember that for the test. Flaps help
you increase your decent angle without
increasing airspeed. But you might be
wondering how this is possible since
flaps also increase lift. Yes, they do,
but they only increase lift if you're
flying the same air speed you were
before you lowered them. But flaps
actually allow us to fly at slower air
speeds, and when you can fly at slower
air speeds, this actually steepens your
descent angle even more.
Now, the reason that flaps allow us to
fly at slower air speeds is because
flaps actually decrease the stall speed
of an airplane, which actually makes it
safer to use them. In fact, take a look
at the stall speed on this Cessna 172
Sierra. When we have the flaps up, the
airplane stalls somewhere around 48
knots. But if we were to lower the flaps
all the way down, the airplane could
actually fly eight knots slower before
it stalled. In fact, the approach and
landing speeds for most airplanes are
actually based on stall speed. The
landing speed for most airplanes is
usually somewhere around 1.3 times the
stall speed in the landing configuration
or VSO. In other words, your landing
speed only gets you a safety buffer if
you have the flaps down. And this means
when you're practicing landings with the
flaps up, you need to be landing a
little bit faster to protect yourself
from stalling the airplane because
landing speed is based on you having the
flaps all the way down, not flaps up.
But that creates a small problem. Flying
faster might keep us from stalling, but
it also makes the airplane float more
during the landing. And that increases
your landing distance. This might not be
a big deal if you're practicing landings
on a runway that's 2 mi long, but it
could certainly be a problem if you're
landing on a 1,000-ft runway. By the
way, if you're struggling with landings,
I wrote a book that you might be
interested in. It's a complete guide to
how to make smooth, precise landings.
It's called the triangle method, and you
can get a digital copy of this book on
my website at free pilot training.net
for $10. Or if you like paper books like
this one, you can get this on Amazon. I
think it's like 29 bucks right now. But
anyway, flaps can make landings so much
safer and easier because they allow you
to fly at slower air speeds. But, flaps
can also be a huge help on takeoffs as
well. In fact, for most training
airplanes, some of the takeoffs you're
going to be learning require the use of
flaps as well. For example, most Cessnas
recommend 10° of flaps during soft field
takeoffs.
And some of the Cessna 172s require the
use of flaps during short field takeoff.
This is because flaps increase lift like
we talked about earlier.
In fact, not too many people know this,
but most airplanes are designed so that
anytime you use 50% or less flaps, the
wings will create more lift than drag.
And if you use more than 50% of the
flaps, the airplane's wings will create
more drag than lift. That's why you can
really drop the airplane super fast if
you lower the flaps all the way down
during an approach. So, if you're ever
super high, don't be afraid to use all
the flaps. That's what they're there
for. In fact, the C130 actually uses 50%
flaps for all takeoffs because that is
the max lift configuration for that
specific airplane.
And that's why we can take off in
ridiculously short distances, in case
you're wondering.
So, not only can flaps increase your
decent angle during a landing, they can
also shorten your takeoff and landing
distances as well if they're used
according to the aircraft flight manual
or the pilot's operating handbook. In
fact, this is going to be your best
friend when you start your flight
training. You're going to hear me say
this over and over again, but every
airplane is different. So, the POH is an
important document that you need to be
familiar with during your training. In
fact, let me show you something kind of
cool about these newer Cessna 172s with
more powerful engines. Notice here that
by using 10° of flaps on this particular
model, you can actually reduce your
total distance over an obstacle by as
much as 10%. This means that the flaps
actually improve the climb angle on this
particular aircraft as well. We'll be
talking about this more in an upcoming
lesson, but in order to get the best
angle possible, you have to fly a
specific airspeed so the airplane can
climb like a beast over these obstacles.
>> So, flaps can give you a lot of options
as a pilot, and once again, landing with
flaps can make things a lot safer when
you're coming in for an approach.
>> With that in mind, your instructor is
going to have you practice landings in
all flap configurations, and that's
because there are times when it might
actually be beneficial to land with less
flaps. One particular time this might be
handy is during gusty crosswinds. Flaps
are really subject to gusty winds. When
the flaps are lowered, the airplane can
get tossed around quite a bit. That's
probably one downside to them, but
overall, they still make flying way
safer because they reduce stall speed.
Now, there are four common types of
flaps that you should be familiar with
as a pilot. Keep in mind, some airplanes
don't have flaps. This is more common on
some of the older airplanes. I guess
people weren't buying these as often
because they realized how awesome flaps
were.
Anyway, the first type of flap you might
see is a plain flap. These are the most
basic type of flaps. These are attached
to the trailing edge of the wing, and
they work a lot like the ailerons
through a hinge mechanism directly
behind the trailing edge of the wing.
Split flaps, on the other hand, are
deflected from the lower surface of the
airfoil. The hinges on these are
underneath the wings. This allows the
flaps to be completely separate from the
wing surface since the flaps move
separately from the wing itself. Slotted
flaps are the most common flaps in use
today. These are similar to plain flaps,
but they allow air to flow over the
upper surface of the flap to increase
lift while still providing the drag
needed for slow flight.
Fowler flaps are a type of slotted flap.
Slotted flaps have simple hinges on the
trailing edge of the wing, which allows
them to lower, but a Fowler flap
actually allows the flap to move back
and down. Not only does this allow
airflow over the top of the flap like
the regular slotted flap, but it also
increases the surface area of the wing,
which significantly improves the lift
that our wings produce because they're
increasing the camber of the wing.
Now, there's actually quite a bit more
information when it comes to the
different types of flaps. So, if you
want to go in more detail on that, be
sure to check out the Pilot's Handbook
of Aeronautical Knowledge in chapter 6.
But, this is everything I think you
should know about and everything you
need to know for the written exam. Hey,
I want to thank you for joining me today
on Free Pilot Training. If you enjoyed
this video, please smash that like
button for me. And if you need a free
copy of the Pilot's Handbook of
Aeronautical Knowledge, be sure to check
out my website at freepilottraining.net.
You'll find that over there for free and
a bunch of other stuff that I know you
guys are going to love. Thanks for
[music] watching.
>> [music]
[music]